be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from Comics explained and talk to me
directly and
CH and to make L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
and so as we get into our discussion
about Thor there's a couple things we
need to go over first the first thing is
that Thor's history is as convoluted as
it is lengthy it is ridiculously in
depth and so in truth if we were going
to do a full in-depth explanation video
on Thor it would take us an hour and I'm
not going to make an hour long video so
what we're going to do here is there are
a couple things we're going to highlight
a couple things that we're going to go
over here of course one of the most
notable is going to be bet Ray Bill but
the other thing is going to be Ragnarok
and the reason why is because Ragnarok
is a very very important element in
Thor's continuity and Ragnarok actually
leads directly into Thor returning to
the Marvel landscape after the events of
Civil War which of course again is
something that we'll discuss here but
with Thor's initial introduction in
Marvel Comics you actually appears in
journey into mystery isue number 83 now
with Thor's initial introduction this is
where things get very confusing for a
lot of people when we're first
introduced to Thor we're introduced to a
man named Donald Blake and Donald Blake
as he's shown to us is a man who is
apparently vacationing in Europe but
also has a bad leg and is holding a cane
now what happens is that as he's
beginning to leave this particular area
that aliens land behind him now he's
initially not aware of it but it
eventually comes to a point where he
becomes aware of their presence and when
he does he immediately tries to run away
now as he's making his way to a
particular cave that has caught his eye
he actually loses his Cane in the
process and so at this point he really
doesn't have a way to move very fast he
doesn't have a way to really get to
where he needs to go very fast and so as
a result he's kind of resigned himself
to his fate and so as he's sitting in
this cave he's leaning against a rock
and when it does the rock seems to maybe
turn around or seems to swivel in some
capacity and reveal a hidden Cavern but
once he gets inside this Cavern he sees
what appears to be a a very old cane
sitting on a table of some kind
and and as a result he really feels as
though this is maybe the the Fate's
playing a joke on him he feels as though
perhaps he's a person who's basically
just going to die in this Cavern and so
what he does is he grabs the cane and he
smacks it against the wall in
frustration and when he does the cane
turns into the hammer of Thor and he
turns into Thor and so he looks at the
cane I'm sorry he looks at the hammer
and he sees that on the hammer is an
inscription and of course this is an
inscription that's well known in the
realm of of Pop Culture media in general
of course the inscription reading
whosoever holds this hammer if he be
worthy shall possess the power of Thor
and so what he realizes here is that he
is now Thor and so he begins to give us
this explanation on what it is that he
knows in the realm of Thor what he
recalls about the character of Thor and
what he says is that as far as he can
remember that Thor had a wide array of
different abilities at his disposal but
one of the first thing he learns is that
if he puts the hammer down that is to
say if he stops touching the hammer for
any more than what appears to be 60
seconds then uh he'll revert back to his
Donald Blake form now in the original
introduction of Thor that is to say in
this comic Marvel doesn't actually give
us a time frame all we see is that he
puts the hammer down he lets go of it
and it seems to be for some amount of
time and then it reverts back to his
normal form realizing that he has to
hold the hammer in order to maintain the
form of Thor it actually won't be until
later on in Marvel Comics so Marvel will
establish a 60-second window that as
long as he is holding the hammer he I
guess as long as you grabs it within 60
seconds after letting it go that uh
he'll I guess he'll maintain his form of
Thor and this is the reason why why
whenever you look at the character of
Thor he's somehow got the hammer on his
back or he's got it on his hip or in
some way the hammer is physically
touching his body it's basically a way
for Marvel to kind of build this element
into it and so what happens here is that
again as he goes over the information
that he recalls about Thor he tells us
that Thor seems to be the only person
who can lift his hammer or lift the
hammer of Muir due to the fact that the
hammer is so heavy now again this is a
very early Thing Marvel will come back
later on and say that it's not simply
the weight of the hammer that keeps
people from being able to wield it's
also the worthiness of that person again
tying into the inscription and so what
we'll find later on as we get into
characters like bet Ray Bill is that
there are a handful of characters who
can wield Thor's hammer but the
characters are only in a handful of
people there's really not that many
folks and so what happens is he begins
experimenting again with this hammer and
he says that uh if he I guess if he
throws the hammer that the hammer will
return to him it will come back which of
course he does he also says that if he
hits the ground twice with the hammer
that it allows him to manipulate weather
now this does not give him I guess the
same kind of finite control that storm
has but it gives him the ability to
create way rain storms to create
thunderstorms and and so on and so forth
that would ultimately result in massive
tornadoes ability to control lightning
and different things like that and then
if he hits it on the hits it on the
ground three times that it would bring
the storm to an end and so one of the
final things that he realizes again that
is that if he Taps the hammer on the uh
on the ground once that it'll turn him
back into Donald Blake which is going to
be a reoccurring theme along his
character when going about uh I guess
going about his existence as a superhero
but again what happens here is that over
the course of the remainder of this
comic he uses his Newfound powers to
defeat the aliens and then goes back to
Empire State University as a surgeon or
as a doctor performing his work and then
being a superhero in his off time now
while all these original Comics were
being introduced while all these
original characters were were coming
into the Thor Comics we saw some of the
Main Stays appearing at the same time in
issue number 84 we saw Jane Foster here
in the Thor continuity and Janee Foster
as she was initially introduced to us
was a woman that Thor was very much in
love with but who he didn't believe
actually returned her affections but in
truth Marvel tells us that it is that
way that she's simply just waiting for
him to say something now initially it's
very hesitant for Donald Blake to
actually get out there and to really I
guess make his feelings known to her
perhaps for fear of rejection we don't
know what the exact reason is here but
as far as he explains it I guess maybe
giving us some insight here is that he
feels as though maybe there's some
element of her that really wouldn't want
to be associated with a guy who has any
kind of a limp or physical weakness but
again this may just be one part of the
equation as to why he doesn't make his
advances known to her but what we also
see is that in issue number 85 Loki
appears now Loki's appearance in the
Thor continuity is a major thing and the
reason why is because Loki will be one
of the most enduring foes in the entire
Thor continuity he will always come back
now sometimes he'll fight on behalf of
Thor if the situation is grave enough
but nine times out of 10 he's usually
always causing some kind of trouble now
what's really interesting here about
Loki's introduction into the Marvel
continuity is that the way that he's
brought in really ties into the kind of
thing that you would expect to see in
Norse mythology and that's what Jack
Kirby and Stanley did when they
introduced Thor they would constantly
get into this North Norse mythology it
would constantly bring in elements that
would seem like something you would see
in Norse mythology and with Loki he had
previously been confined to a tree for
causing trouble he had actually been I
guess isolated inside of this tree and
the only way for him to escape was if
somebody in Asgard had basically shed a
tear for his plight but because he was
basically the most hated person there
that wasn't going to happen but over the
years what he had done was learned to
manipulate the tree and so when um when
heimall came by who of course was the
guardian of the bifrost which allowed
the asgardians to travel from one realm
to another he had basically caused a I
guess a leaf to slip or to fall away
from a tree branch and it landed in the
eye of Heimdall which caused Heimdall to
shed a tear and as a result Loki was
able to leave now the way that he did
this was really kind of interesting he
basically bypassed the imprisonment by
saying that his plight was being stuck
in a tree because he was able to
manipulate the tree that he was stuck in
he was able to get out but again these
are very early comics for for Marvel
with regards to Stanley and Jack Kirby
and so a lot of these things don't
necessarily make sense now but they made
made a lot of sense back then and so
what we do as we continue with this is
we see that in journeying to mystery
issue number 97 that the tales of Asgard
appear now the tales of Asgard were a
series of stories that had been
introduced in the stories of Thor that
would basically fill in the gaps they
would tell us a lot of the things that
went on in the past of Asgard that led
things to where they are now for example
some of the stories involving the
conflicts that Thor himself was involved
in alongside Loki as a child some of the
conflicts that Odin had been involved in
that had led to the modern day formation
of Asgard and different things like that
now one of the other things that we had
seen was that Marvel had taken the
journey into mystery stories and they
had basically converted the Entre ire
comic to a Thor story and so what they
what we saw was that by issue number 104
of journey into mystery the name had
been changed to journey in the mystery
with the Mighty Thor and it was
basically just marvel converting slowly
altering the entire journey into mystery
publication into Thor solo comic and the
reason why is because Thor's stories had
really began to overshadow anything else
that was appearing in journey into
mystery it was really at a point now
where the journey in mystery stories
revolved around Thor and so it was the
easiest way for Marvel to begin
transitioning things and this continued
along this entire concept this continued
along this path again we saw with this
shared continuity that uh we saw various
characters like Magneto and the
Brotherhood of evil mutants for example
appearing in issue number 109 of journey
into mystery we saw that with journey in
mystery issue number 108 that doctor
strange had appeared and so again this
was just a way for Marvel to continue
this trend it was a way for Marvel to I
guess bring things in but one of the
other things that we saw and this was
really an important point in the history
of uh of Thor's Comics was that in issue
number 112 of journey into mystery that
we ultimately saw the Avengers begin to
take form now what had happened here is
that the Incredible Hulk had basically
been goated into attacking or I guess
going on a rampage and so we saw Thor
alongside name of the Submariner and the
original Avengers come together to try
to hold the Incredible Hulk off and so
this was an instance whereby Thor had
hypothesized the idea that the Avengers
should form the Avengers should take
place they should be a team that
operates under the guise of protecting
the war World from dangerous threats
when nobody else can and so again as we
continue to move forward with this we
ultimately see that with issue number
113 the Thor Reveals His identity to
Jane Foster and this was a really big
moment here because keeping in mind this
entire time up to this point Thor's been
operating with dual identities he's been
Donald Blake whenever it was that he
didn't need to be didn't need to be Thor
and he was Thor whenever it was that he
had to get involved in some kind of a
conflict here but he had always had an
interest in uh in Jane Foster he had
always really enjoyed the company of
Jane Foster while the two of them had
previously sort of gotten together she
didn't know that he was Thor she didn't
know that he was two people now what we
also see is that by March of
1966 that Marvel basically converts the
entire journey into mystery series over
into Thor's solo series that is to say
they get rid of the journey into mystery
name and they simply call it uh Thor I'm
sorry the Mighty Thor what they also do
here is they get rid of tales of Asgard
and this is where we started seeing
Publications like the Inhumans coming
into play in Marvel Comics is when we
started seeing them I guess appearing in
Thor stories which would again go on to
Spur the Inhumans into popularity here
what we also see is that in issue number
159 that we actually get the full
original background of Thor and this is
something that took quite a long time
for Jack Kirby and Stanley to come up
with something for them to introduce to
us and what we learned with this actual
backstory here is that Donald Blake is
really looking to to find out what's
going on he's really looking to find out
how it is that Thor had ended up in a
position to where is now and so what he
does is he begins speaking I guess with
Odin using uh I guess an attempt to
communicate with him using his mind but
it's more or less like a shared dream
state I guess might be the best way to
explain it here but what Odin basically
tells Donald Blake is that Thor had
previously had I guess he had courage he
had everything that was befitting of a
prince of Asgard but he wasn't humble he
didn't have humility and so what he had
done is he had cast Thor to the planet
Earth and then put him in the body of a
man named Donald Blake I guess assign
him to that kind of a role which in turn
also gave him a limp now Odin says that
he had also put the hammer under this
under the disguise of being a Cain in
the cave where Donald Blake had
initially found it hoping that Donald
Blake would find it one day but the
entire purpose here was to force Thor to
live among the humans or live among
Humanity I guess Mortals as they would
call us um in an effort to basically
teach him how to be uh humble to teach
him humility so that he could truly
understand what it meant to govern over
those who are weaker than he is but do
it in a way to where it benefits all and
so eventually as we continue on we see
that Jack Kirby actually leaves the Thor
series with issue number
179 and that Neil Adams one of Marvel's
I guess Premier artists at the time had
taken over to draw V draw a couple
comics with issues number 180 and issues
number 189 I'm sorry 181 what we also
saw was that by issue number 279 that uh
Stan Lee had left the series and so with
issue number 280 that Roy Thomas had
come into play now Roy Thomas wrote some
pretty interesting stories but Roy
Thomas would not nearly be as important
of a writer for Thor's continuity as
Walt Simonson when Walt Simonson was
introduced in 1983 with volume1 issue
number 337 Walt Simonson had done a lot
of stories that had really revolved
around the element of Thor had really
focused on Thor that is to say the
mythology for example we saw that with
issue number
344 that malakith had first appeared in
the Marvel continuity and again this was
one of the characters who would go on to
continue to be a major foe in the realm
of uh of of Thor's continuity we had
seen that in issue number
367 uh I'm sorry with um issue number
337 that that Beta Ray Bill had appeared
in Marvel's continuity Now Beta Ray Bill
appearing as far as the the Thor
mythology is a very important thing and
the reason why is because prior to bet
Ray Bill there had never been anyone who
had been able to wield Thor's hammer it
had never been seen before it seemed as
though Thor was the only person who
could actually wield his own hammer and
that anybody else who tried simply just
wouldn't be able to pick it up but what
we had seen is that Marvel had basically
made it okay for people to wield Thor's
hammer and fans weren't very upset with
this in fact fans really enjoy the
concept of bet Ray Bill this is
considered to be one of the greatest
moments in the Run of Walt Simonson when
it came to the character of Thor and so
what we saw was that Marvel had to be
very tentative in the future when it
came to the idea of people who were
wielding beta um wielding uh Thor's
hammer we saw that in the Marvel and DC
crossover for example that Superman was
able to wield a hammer we saw that
Captain America was able ble to wield
the hammer we saw that only the most I
guess prized people in comic book
continuity were able to wield Thor's
hammer but nobody else was able to do
that and so again as we continue with
this video what we do is we pick up with
the story of Ragnarok now Ragnarok is a
story that a lot of people are really
really intrigued about due to the idea
of the Thor Ragnarok film coming out and
we can do I guess a separate video that
really gets us a little more in depth or
we can talk about the events of Thor
Ragnarok but what it basically happened
here was that this was the equivalent of
the end of times for the Asgardian
Universe this was basically a
circumstance where we learned that there
were beings who existed called the ones
who sit in Shadow I believe and these
were per these were were beings who
basically had either perpetuated or
possibly even created the cycle of the
Asgardian Universe being destroyed and
then being reborn and what they would do
is they would feed on this cycle it
would be their sustenance it' be a way
for them to keep themselves going and So
what had basically been happening for an
unknown amount of time for countless
eons is that the Thor universe or the
the Asgardian Universe would come to an
end and then it would be reborn and so
Odin would come back Thor would come
back Loki would come back they would
live their lives and then everything
would come to an end and it would start
all over again now again we don't know
exactly how long this had gone on for
but the entire basis behind the Ragnarok
concept was that as a result Thor at the
end of the story had basically
sacrificed his life to destroy the ones
who sit in Shadow and so as a result
once we got around to the Civil War
conflict Thor was presumed to have been
dead simply existed inside of a void he
really just wasn't alive here and so
what we do is we pick up with volume
three and volume three picks up after
the events of Civil War of the main
Civil War conflict this I think actually
picks up during the uh the post Civil
War initiative event which again was a
uh a 30-some series of comics I think
that Marvel had published with the
intention of picking up after the events
of Civil War but what had happened here
is Thor had basically arrived back to
the Marvel landscape and he had found
that of course Ragnarok or I guess the
character who would be called Ragnarok
had been made the cyborg version of
floor which was made by Reed Richards
and H Pim and and Tony Stark and of
course he was you know awfully angry
about this but at the same time what we
had also found was that his desire was
to bring Asgard back because again after
the events of Thor Ragnarok everybody
had died everybody in Asgard had been
killed off there were no more asgardians
and so as a result Thor had actually
formed Asgard in the middle of Oklahoma
and then went about the process of
waking people up and what we had learned
over the course of volume three is that
the asgardians were in some capacity
still alive but the minds of men and
women were basically portals that would
allow them to come back in the sense
that uh that heimdal for example was I
guess occupying the body of a man who
was very rebellious against anybody who
entered his town post Civil War he was
very strong about protecting that town
and so what what Thor had done was
basically awaken this man and bring uh
bring heimall out of him and then
restore Heimdall back to the Earth 616
continuity but nonetheless as things
progress with Thor we ultimately saw
that while Thor posts Stanley and Jack
Kirby and even post Walt Simonson it had
some ups and downs while it had some
interesting Concepts to it that overall
Thor's continuity sort of began to drop
off it sort of began to slump as the
years went by which ultimately leads up
to the current Day in 2014 when we find
that Marvel has basically eliminated
Thor Odin son as being the actual Thor
and replaced him with a woman whose
identity we yet don't
know with that being said we're going to
go ahead and bring this video to an end
I hope you guys enjoyed it if you did
let me know and I will catch you guys
later
[Music]
peace